hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
uh back to reviewing products
this is a speaker i just tested and i
thought i'd share with you in video as
well as the uh
texture view that's out it's the bauer
and wilkins
607 s2 anniversary edition
um it's a bookshelf speaker
that was sent by a member to me costs
about
700 and it's only sold through their
dealers
at least i didn't think i saw it on
amazon and what have you
uh before i do reviews or while i'm
doing the measurements i usually go hunt
around for other reviews there are
hardly any on on this anniversary
edition or even the s2 version
i found a couple one is this british
what hi-fi
site and they raved about it
excuse me five stars and
improved clarity and detail uh more
expressive
a tighter more agile bass
wonders what those things mean and
nothing negative at this price really
uh very surprised um
steve guttenberg uh reviewed this
product
uh twice he did a review of it and then
he picked it as speaker of the year for
last year i think he picked two speakers
this was one of the two
and uh i'll let you go and uh watch his
videos so
uh uh the uh praise seems to be uh
unanimous at least uh
as far as you can go with just two
reviews
um but of course they don't
properly evaluate the speaker my opinion
they don't do any objective analysis and
uh
heaven knows how their subjective
analysis is going uh
uh you know they just play some music
and comment on
on the how they felt at the end anyway
um this speaker comes in different
colors the version i had was in
black you can see it back here sitting
here
um i guess it it looks alright um
i can't say it looks any more
exceptional than any other speaker
has this grill on top of a twitter that
seems to be
becoming common with a few companies
using them elac
and bmw here and i think
a paradigm speaker use them uh some
people call them
uh uh sync uh uh
train hold mesh or something because it
sort of looks like that but
uh they look nicer than that um the
corners are unfortunately quite sharp
and the reason that matters is that they
get diffraction the sound wave as they
hit in here they start to generate their
own little mini speakers
around these corners and you know you're
starting to get to a price at seven
hundred dollars that you expect somebody
to at least
round over the edges of of these
cabinets and use thick enough
material to allow that kind of round
over to happen
um so it doesn't look ugly but i don't
think it looks like a luxury product
which you should
because you can get bookshelf speakers
for 120
150 dollars in this size so when you pay
700
you expect more i'd say the back
actually it looks more attractive to me
this
very large flared port
and very clever uh design from
manufacturing point of view
that they took this cup this plastic
come and integrated it with the
with the port so they had to pay for
tooling only once and
uh for some believe it's easy you just
snap this whole thing in there screw it
in and you got both things
in there i was a little surprised to see
uh
these binding posts not being in gold
coating not that it matters much but
that seems to be the norm to uh you know
give a feeling of uh
luxury on that but uh they passed on it
um i don't know how many people try to
buy wire these things but uh
there it is speakers manufacturing china
as just about every speaker below
thousand dollars usually is and
even above a thousand dollars so nothing
against that as long as they have their
own
supervision of how things get
manufactured in china it should be fine
um on this thing so if you haven't seen
it
or read about my speaker measurements
which is what i lead
with and then get into a listening test
i use
what's called the near field scanner
from one of the leaders in
driver and speaker uh design and
analysis a
company called clipple in germany they
make this robotic uh
scanner which i have purchased you put
the speaker on it
and then this arm moves the microphone
measurement microphone that you can see
it goes up and down
and makes a scan all the way around it
actually does it twice
and by doing that it's able to
get a full 3d representation of of the
sound waves around the speaker and then
you can query the
software and say give me the response at
this position and 3d space
you know at any arbitrary position i use
about a thousand measurement points you
can pick that
and that's my standard for typical
speakers
and uh that takes about two and a half
hours and another half hour of signal
processing time
on my fast pc to generate the sound
field and the measurements you're going
to see
using the system you don't need an
anechoic chamber and you don't even need
a quiet room because it makes
measurements very close to the speakers
so ambient noise
gets excluded a lot
so uh going back to the uh uh
measurements um that entire 3d
set of measurements can summarize into
what we call the spin
graph or spinorama this term comes from
harmon that started this innovation and
before that
uh research done by dr floyd tull
at canadian research council and
where they took all the
measurements in you know directly
looking at the speaker but also
above and below vertically and also
horizontally 72 measurement
points and then they summarize them into
a bunch of graphs in here so it's a lot
easier to analyze than looking at 72
frequency response measurements
so the solid line that you see says on
axis is the most important one because
that's the
main sound that directly comes from the
speaker and hits your ear first
all the other sounds have to reflect
from wall or multiple surfaces before
they
come to your ear so if we look at the on
axis response
what we want to see is a neutral speaker
and with no ups and downs as much as a
speaker can be
here unfortunately we see the exact
opposite of if you look in here we have
some kind of irregularity here which is
unusual then we have
another chunk over here that goes up
whenever you see these curves follow the
same kind of
peaking that means there's a resonance
there that means if you tap on something
it'll ring on its own
and that colors the sound so we know we
have a resonance here we have resonance
here
and then we get a hole in what should be
the crossover region and the number one
job of a crossover
designer is to design those two curves
for the woofer and the twitter
to average out to be a flat response
not have a hole in it uh very puzzling
while people still make speakers with
this kind of hole in it
and then the response shoots way up
another resonance here
around five or six kilohertz uh
and then another one up here probably
twitter itself
uh potentially and at any rate this
entire region is elevated
above uh one thousand to the three
thousand hertz or so
so uh just looking at this i can tell
you the speaker's
not going to be neutral um it's gonna
impart this tonality on everything you
play
and it's hard to imagine that every
recorded music in the world
comes with an inverse of this graph so
that this correction makes it sound
neutral
uh it's about you know is it the worst
i've seen
probably not but i'd say it's probably
ranks way down there as far as how bad
it is
so that's the first thing i look at this
on axis response and then the second one
is this early reflections those are the
most important
and loudest reflections that also arrive
at your ear and combine with a direct
sound
so if they are very different in
tonality than the on-axis response
then they can actually shift the
tonality and potentially
be you know something that's not as
pleasant you hear
the ear wants to ignore those
reflections because they're delayed in
timing can be confusing
and the brain wants to filter them out
because it's not additional information
about what the source of sound is
but to the extent they have their own
tonality and what have you is it can't
do that
so excuse me let's look at the uh
this uh earlier reflection here and
uh up here the blue and you can see it
in this dashed line
this dashed line ideally would track be
the same distance
from this ship from on axis all the way
but we can see in some places it
actually gets very close to it
and some places is farther away so
it is not tracking it hundred percent
this has a
consequence in that when on axis is
wrong we can use equalization to pull
that up
but we can't change this relationship
between
on and off axis responsible speaker
because we
our equalization is upstream of a
speaker we can't control
the tonality of the sound that only goes
sideways from it
we only have one electrical input to the
speaker and
two things or multiple things come out
of it and and that's a bad thing
it means electro equalization
potentially doesn't work well
whether you do it manually or
automatically through an avr and what
have you
um on this thing uh very low efficiency
as speakers go
average speaker that i test is 85 to 86
db
efficiency um i measure about 83 over
here the company advertises 84 which is
very honest usually
companies like klipsch will go pick this
peak up here and say that is the
efficiency say it's 90 db over here
should be just crazy wrong
um most power you need for speaker to
drive it is in low frequencies
and this is what matters here how loud
you can make this
and so inefficient speaker despite being
little don't be full thinking you can
get a little
10 watt amplifier to drive it is it's
not gonna
play that that well okay i talked about
the early reflection again we can
actually look at what goes into every
early reflections is reflections from
floor ceiling front wall sidewalls rear
walls and then
the special sum of all these things
together
we get this curve we can see that this
curve is
you know as gnarly as the on-axis one uh
but again it's not identical to it
um and uh it's just not good you don't
want to see this kind of messiness in
here now
if you want to improve this this
messiness you can look at the individual
components
and see which one you should put an
absorber on and
potentially fix improve the situation
like if the floor reflections were bad
you can put a thick carpet on the floor
here i couldn't find any of these curves
that i would want to take out
and uh to fix anything because
you take it out and there's some areas
of the curve of which your reflection is
doing some good some areas is not doing
good
usually i try to fix this dip in here
but nothing is really
in this area uh maybe sidewall
reflections you could take out
will improve but the sidewall
reflections are over here and
um you know and they have a beneficial
effect actually of making the
speaker become wider not just be this
point source which is artificial
anyway the the standard
that we use allows us to take a
combination of
of what's called the powers response
which is the most low frequency dominant
and these early reflections and on axis
and we can synthesize them and predict
what a typical average room
sound would be so everything else i've
shown you has been anechoic which means
no reflections
you know idealized situation where we're
just looking at the speaker not
speak around the room this graph
actually shows speaker and a room so it
says look
most likely if you put the speaker in
the room it is the sound you're going to
get now you could have weird rooms that
don't match this
but it's surprisingly close uh i should
say
i've drawn a trend line by eye
mathematically you could
put a line in there and figure it out
but if you just draw a line and usually
i
try to match it in bass response we're
kind of okay in here a few hundred hertz
and then we have a
bump in here and in upper hundreds of
hertz then we have a dip
then we have this massive peaking so
bulk of your music from a few hundred
hertz on
is going to be subjected to this fixed
eq
which i just can't imagine this being a
you know a pleasant experience
certainly anything up here means higher
pitch and in
extreme the dip in here
is it's a very critical part of music
there's a lot of content in here you
don't want to
spectrum in here in your music you don't
want to pull this down this area that's
up some of it is actually good it can
contribute to a
wider sound stage actually this entire
area does
sort of between one kilos and three
kilohertz the higher this
is the more sense of openness and sound
stage you get because
it's high enough in frequency but also
it's an area where a lot of a channel
separation exists in
in music bass usually is way mono highs
are
just so far inaudible so low in level we
don't care about
this area i feel you got to get right
and this is a mix of
good and bad in here so very hard to
synthesize
what the end result would be it's
possible the reviewers who
love this big air sort of you know they
were hearing this effect when they
talk about you know uh soundstage and
then
there could be food what i call showroom
sound which is
you know boost the crap out of the high
frequencies make it bright
in the first few seconds of listening to
the speaker it'll
sound ultra detailed and refined and
we call that a showroom effect because
in the old days all these speakers were
put on the shelf with a selector a b
switch you just
you know select them and the speaker
that was brightest the
you know classic clips would always win
and also louder
because this this area and it's uh i
gotta tell it's captivating for a few
seconds even for a train listener
at first it sounds good but uh uh longer
term this is where ear fatigue comes
from and uh
and uh you just don't you know it's like
too much chocolate you know too much
sweet
you know a little bit is good in
moderation but not too much
um one test i do is that i take the
microphone
measurement microphone and just make a
single measurement very close to each
driver and the port
that gives us a rough idea of what each
one of them is doing more or less
independently the entire speaker is
playing still
so you get some bleeding effects but
here's the port for example in orange it
goes up in
in here so the port tuning is around 50
hertz
and provides that kick and that's what
the ports do is that they give you some
more
low frequency responses and you can see
the woofer was dying
you know well above that so this
provides a boost
uh but a drawback of the port is that
the sound
also that bounces up and down inside the
cabinet left and right
in three dimensions can create
resonances of its own
proportional to those dimensions if
they're not well damped or well isolated
and instead of a sound continuing to
just go down all sudden starts to go
back because it builds up energy
and we can see a peak over here and see
multiple peaks in here
and if you look at the woofer you see
it's very clean response but where does
all this
uh rockiness come from here like this
one and these
that all comes from port resonances so
that's why this jag and poor response of
the port
is coming on now good news is that the
port's pointed in the back
so unless you put it very close to a
wall
audibility of that is not very huge
normally
but some of it is bleeding enough to
show up in the on access response
uh the twitters here now the relative
levels of these
manually adjust them so not very
accurate but more or less
you can see that the twitter a doesn't
have a
fixed response in here you know it sort
of goes up and it goes back down and and
comes back down here it doesn't have a
clean
flat response to 20 kilohertz it's got
its own peaking over here
they could have just put a resistor in
series without pull that down and made
it much more well behaved
but you know they're clearly aiming for
this kind of
bright sound and the crossover who knows
what the crossover is it looks kind of
gentle slope to me rather than the
steeper slopes that you want to have
when you don't have steeper slopes you
can see that the warfare has resonances
over here
and those start to whack into the
twitter and cause jaggedness there
although this one's fairly low but you
can see the woofer here
isn't just nicely sloping down
it does you know it has all this
screwiness in here and a sharper filter
may have gotten rid of some of this
weirdness in here and some of these are
out of
phase by the way here and they cause
cancellations and that dipped every so
um another i measure the phase and and
the
amplitude of the impedance
and here mostly what i usually note is
how low the
impedance gets is actually not bad most
bookshelves go down to
four or three and a half ohms this one
is five ohms and higher so
it's not going to require a very high
current
amplifier but as i noted it's an
inefficient amp so
it's gonna require more um it's some
power anyway
there are little kinks in here i don't
know if this comes across in
video at all but i'll show you the next
graph where it does one of those little
kinks in here means there's a resonance
there again resonance is where something
inside also
captures energy and starts playing on
its own louder
and that causes sliders taken here
usually i don't show this csd waterfall
because it can be misleading and the
parameters of it can make it look
anything at once i'll probably do a
video on this next
um but here i saw i showed because it
looked
pretty bad you can see all these lines
in here
basically you know we played something
but at certain frequencies
it has no extension here but at other
frequencies all of a sudden
you play the note and you stop and it'll
keep going for it by itself
and if you keep playing then it acts
like this amplifier and it you get these
peaks in here and if you look in here
you can see it corresponds to peaks up
there
so technically so far boy there's not a
whole lot to hang your hat on
um one of the things we look at is how
wide of a
beam horizontally and vertically the
speaker
generates this is fairly typical about
plus or minus 60 degrees probably most
common that i find
but it's very hard to determine where
you should draw the line this is the red
line that we look at where
60 b is lost uh 60 be less loud than the
on axis sound
you can see that it's you know a lot of
chewed up response
up here then it gets okay then it goes
down then it goes up then it goes down
then it goes
it gets narrower again uh clearly there
was no attempt made that
regularizing these uh the
woofer and the twitter for example over
here here we can see the woofer is
getting narrow and also on twitter
kicks in and is wider and
so the two have a mismatch why because
we go back to our
design what should be in here based on
decades of research is that you want to
have a waveguide
that narrows the response of that
twitter so at crossover points so that
when this guy hands the signal to
to the twitter how wide the beam is
doesn't snap from one side to the other
and
the woofer always gets it gets narrower
and narrower
as the frequencies go up and uh because
of its size
and the twitter being a lot smaller has
the inverse as soon as you hand it the
signal
it's much smaller relative to the
wavelength of music
i mean the the sound so it then has a
wider one
a wave guide limits that width of a
tweeter to be
only certain width and it's missing in
here it's really not excusable
at this price range and we can see the
penalty in here
in in this not being smooth we can look
at the same graph as a heat map
counter plot and we can see the damage
is doing right around the crossover how
the
beam width gets narrower and also the
the on axis response it just there's a
lot of variations the dark red in here
means
amplitude is higher the highs but here
we see the amplitude is a way down
and then it goes hard and goes lower
it's frankly a mess there
um vertically is odd as well
usually two-way non-coaxials will not
have the prettiest
vertical directivity thankfully
directivity vertically is
less important than than horizontal one
i won't get into it now but you still
want to have as reasonable
as you can i measured the speaker with
my measurement microphone reference
being the center of that twitter
at the center of twitter you can see
that you're right close to this
area in blue and green which means that
the amplitude is much
lower than it would be otherwise what
this says is that you want to sit above
the twitter level so if you can position
the speaker where
you know sort of the sound is angling up
5 or 10 or 20 degrees
do not go below don't put it at higher
than your ear level on high on a
bookshelf or something
sound pointing down because you'll fall
in this ditch where
you get even bigger dip in here
vertically
than what all of our assumptions uh have
is it all bad news no if you look at the
marketing material from them
they show very nice 3d analysis of the
drivers and how they went from their
older drivers
to add more resonances and distortions
to a cleaner new ones and that
shows especially for your twitter i test
the
speaker at two levels of loudness at one
meter uh
uh 3.3 feet uh of 86 db and 96 db
at 86 db this twitter is just
it's just for speakers essentially less
it's incredible even at 96 db is below
half a percent which is
fantastic this is what some of the best
uh speakers do
um below 100 hertz it's a little driver
it's going to get
woofer it's going to get distorted um
at 960b the woofer's very unhappy
uh actions are very unhappy but unhappy
enough that
the woofer is the weak link in here as
it would be
again in with small woofer like this um
i show that that's percentages of
distortion we can also look at
absolute and i draw a line at 50 db spl
as my reference i'd like to see
everything below that and at 86 db
it it gets there no problem this is a
very low distortion uh
speaker at the 96 db on the right
uh this is typical of the speaker
especially when they have a port
in that if you go below certain
frequency tuning frequency of the port
all
sudden the woofer loses control and
it actually generates more distortion
than the tone itself that you told it to
play
so i said distortion is greater than 100
percent you do not want to have
the speaker play that so sometimes
putting a high pass filter
helps a lot so if you have a subwoofer
to go with this
you would put in that as 80 hertz or
whatever anyway and
if you want to play it loud that's
mandatory so
um a lot of times people ask me why do i
listen i said well you know sometimes
easy
to determine what some sounds like but
if you look at the speaker with
you know highs and lows uh you know
both region you know these regions i
can't give you exactly
you know an impression of what the sound
would be generally i said yeah it's
bright in here but what does this thing
do
so i go and listen and uh i always put
the speaker in the exact same listening
position
and exact same set of tracks exact same
protocol
so just some like 150 speakers that way
and not over 50 years i've done that
over a little over a year so
everything's fresh in my mind of you
know exactly what i'm expecting the
sound to be
and i tell you the first few seconds of
this the marketing angle worked
perfectly
you hear this very detailed high
frequency exaggerated sound that
because of low distortion level is
actually pleasing
uh it's not grading there are speakers
that are
you know have a lot of highs and have
distortion and just immediately you want
to
you know stop the music not so in here
but
if you're at all trained or listened to
any decent speaker
you know after a few seconds you say
well well this
this is not first of all where's the
bass you know i could hardly hear the
bass
i don't know how steve guttenberg says
there's so much space in here you almost
don't need a subwoofer
you know you're just not going to hear
that bass when all these highs are so
elevated
elevated i couldn't hear any bass i mean
it was just all
mid to high frequencies and that's what
he was playing
and uh it just
you know it was it's just not pleasant
the other thing is though was that the
little bit of bass that was there was
his tubbiness
was weird it wasn't real bass but there
was some tubbiness
and i suspect that tubbiness comes from
that elevated resonances that were in a
few
you know a few hundred hertz that was
giving the impression of bass somewhat
of an impression pace
but it's the wrong basis because the
resonances are not good
so i brought up my uh eq tools in the
roon media player i use what's nice
about roon is that it has a digital
pipeline
and you can just turn on a signal
processing module of your choice in this
case i'm using
parametric eq parametric eq means i can
pick a frequency
that i want to have the highest
attenuation
or amplification and i can set the width
and i can set how high
that um that level is so three
parameters it's got a frequency
and it's got the amplitude and it's got
the width and this width is called the
queue
and i'm showing you all the ones that i
did um
so working from the uh i don't know
working from the left to
right this is that first little dip that
was uh at around 500 hertz
uh it's not very audible it's just a
slight amount but i thought it got rid
of that tubbiness and a boominess
then we had a larger resonance this is
basically inverse of what you saw
in the on-axis frequency response or the
predicted in-room response
brought that second resonance down there
was a hole there i pulled the hole
up and then there was a resonance over
here
knocked that down wasn't enough then i
had to put what is called a
sheldon filter where i take an entire
region or bring it down
once i did all this it transformed the
speaker
um you did give up some of that ah there
was this all these highs
yeah that were artificial high so you
lose a little bit of that
this compensation where i'm pulling up
the mid-range
you know it actually counters that
pretty well but it's now listenable
as soon as i did this though a new
problem popped up which i didn't put in
a review i forgot
which was all sudden so now i'm taking
all these levels down
so overall the speaker is less loud so
you now crank it up and you actually
hear bass the bass comes in
but there is no dynamic head drumming in
that woofer
once you turn it up and cranks with some
power
it bottoms out and it bottoms out in a
really nasty way a good puck
you know all sudden you lose control so
if you were going to do this you'd need
to put another high pass filter in here
and kill some of the deep lows
and the challenge with that is that when
you do that you actually lose some of
your base
and i didn't go there at this point i
stopped
uh five filters is way too many filters
to put in to fix the speaker that
comes at a premium price of almost
double of what another speaker would
cost
not only that you're becoming a speaker
designer what speaker designer should
have done was correct all this stuff and
designed a speaker that didn't need this
much mucking around with
here you have to do that you can start
with my set but i tell you it's not
perfect
members we have a senior member who does
this mechanically where it goes and
creates a true inverse of that
graph that may work may not work yet uh
it's just you know it's borderline
unacceptable as far as what i would even
do
with you know the skill i have in trying
to fix the speaker
um one of the issues i want to guard
against
is that i don't want to you know
our mood is not always the same and
you could wake up one day where you know
maybe you got algae some
as i often do maybe your higher high
frequency hearing is shot or maybe
you're not in good mood so
i often when i get something like this i
go ahead and
put in one of the speakers that i know
it's not too expensive
uh but i know that it sounds good just
to say
you know what this music really sounds
like when it's properly done
and i usually pull up this uh um
m105 that's just sitting there ready to
go
uh it's double the price so don't get me
wrong but boy
i turned that on i'm like
no eq whatsoever i'm like ah this this
is what music's supposed to sound like
it's just even with all my equalization
i did not get close to the sound of this
producer
it was just a delight i don't know
it's just they're not in the same planet
and
uh you know and you can tell that from
measurements i've shown you
and i can tell you in a controlled
listening with exact same speaker exact
same music exact same position
that revealed which follows four decades
of research on what's what is a good
speaker
just cleans the clocks of of this
speaker
so you know that's what's done now it
didn't need to cost double the amount
uh bmw clearly has the technical jobs
to have designed a better crossover to
design a wave guide in there better
optimize the position of the two drivers
the cabinet the corners the diffraction
all of that is well within their means
to do right
but either they're saving money or
they think this is sound that sells uh
or some other motivation to build
basically broken speakers
in the marketing material they're saying
the 600 series has sold a million
units since inception in 94 whenever the
first one came out
so i suspect they have this uh internal
uh idea of continuing that i don't know
how good about the older generation
sounded
but i can tell you this is not a speaker
that should be on on your buying list
whatsoever let alone be highly
recommended let alone be
speaker of the year steve
guttenberg what are you listening to
i mean i'm not a spring chicken i
frequency hearing is also
reduced substantially so when the
speaker sounds so bright to me
how could it not sound bright to him is
it that he has no high frequency
left in his hearing or that he doesn't
follow a protocol which i think likely
the case he keeps playing different
music with every speaker
that is the wrong thing to do if you
keep playing different
music that you don't know what parts of
them are revealing what parts don't
bring out these issues
yeah you can get music and you can play
it on this speaker and you can go to
town
there's plenty of good sounding music
that will sound good on this and it may
sound great if you have no frame of
reference you don't have a protocol you
don't have a system for evaluating
subjectively and of course she never did
any
measurements either i have the luxury of
cheating because the measurements tell
me
hey this is not a good speaker still i
should tell you by the way when i was
evaluating the speaker i did not have
the measurements in front of me i
measured it all and but i did not
extract the measurement
and i listened and then once it noticed
the brightness
i went back and pulled out the graph and
then i started to build the eq
but uh that's the benefit of measurement
it gives you a compass it gives you a
router it says look
there are issues here don't listen for
it there are too much eyes in here
there's a hole in here
are they audible are they not so i built
the filter
and i turned these on and off that's
okay there was a hole in here
if i compensate for it one of two things
happens
either sounds better or sounds worse
because there's pretty
big change in here if it sounds better
means the measurements were correct
if it sounds worse then i said some bad
measurements i'm not understanding
you know it's a complex sound field
hitting the walls and everything
but i'll tell you what folks are doing
for evaluating
speakers subjectively is beyond you know
my comprehension logic of how you can
take a speaker like this
and praise it as perfect with zero flaws
you know how does have this i mean if
this is perfect
what is imperfect i mean what could you
have done worse than this
to make this imperfect i i just can't
fathom
how speaking little like this so
inefficient could have a lot of bass
how could it have a lot of bass you have
no power or you know it's just so
inefficient
and it's sloping down it no way does it
go down to 20 30 amps or whatever i mean
you're just way down here
and it's overwhelmed by the highs
now going back to bmw i i mean my
request to them is first if they think
these things are wrong go ahead and
publish your own measurements contact me
i'd love to know that i'm wrong about
these things
don't just talk about the drivers and
what material goes in the woofer i don't
care what material goes in that woofer
if it resonates and it bottoms out it's
broken
i'm not here to design speakers it's
their job don't tell me about what
how hard you worked to do that i mean i
don't want to know whoever
makes sand to build a brick that went on
our house
you know i just wonder if the brick is
mounted straight and now's not going to
fall over
uh yeah you have a twitter which has
very low distortion
but why the heck did you create a hole
in here and a peak in here and all these
resonance speaks
what school of acoustics have they gone
to which
papers which research you know we we've
been building speakers for a century
almost
it is not a new thing people have really
spent time
analyzing these things to find out
what's a good speaker what's a good bad
speaker what sounds good what doesn't
sound good
you know if you're going to violate that
so dramatically
give us some insight give us a paper you
know bring in a panel listeners do
something rather than
saying oh my gosh armory great we sold a
million of these speakers we got this
other one
we're going to call it the anniversary
edition but golly don't do anything to
smooth out this response i mean they you
know there are di wires who can go in
and improve the response of the speaker
i mean i i'm not a speaker designer and
my specialty is understanding speaker
performance
but now i can go and design it but i
know i can go in there put a resistor in
line with the twitter
pull this sucker down down here at least
not have
your ears bleed and by the way anytime
you pull these things down distortion
goes even lower
it's one benefit of pulling these peaks
down is that you're not asking the
speaker to work as hard so you're
pulling those down so you actually get
better performance
anyway very disappointing major company
british company with
decades of experience uh in this day and
age where the science is so well
understood as far as
the principles of what you shouldn't do
wrong
million ways to design speakers to fit
that principle by the way so it doesn't
stifle innovation whatsoever
as you know there are a million speakers
looking like this but
don't go you know take every piece of
music i
listen to and you say i'm gonna decide
i'm gonna change the tonality of
everything
amir listens to because just me
you know i'm bmw i'm going to tell you
that your music should have this kind of
mishmash i wonder if they think this is
great whether all over their speakers
are identical responses
some tells me that there isn't it's just
these errors that they're letting
through anyway i'm ranting a lot
uh you know according to my opinion
objective subjective listening test
everything that i can do to analyze
a speaker tells me this is absolutely
the wrong speaker the reviewers who are
saying these are
top you know best of 22. i just
can't fathom they're doing a disservice
to their audience to their viewers
and steering towards you know the
technology just doesn't give you good
sound in your room
get a proper speaker enjoy and sit back
and you have a lifetime investment
because these speakers don't become
obsolete they don't need
feed tax and formats a bunch of them
things like that until they fall apart
they can give it 20 30 years of good
experience get one that's properly
designed
that's objectively great and
subjectively great
it is not hard i must have tested 30 to
40 speakers in a year alone
that meet both of those criterias um get
an active speaker instead of these
little things
uh they're just beautiful many of them
are just designed to have the right
combination of amplification crossover
and what have you anyway you can tell
have strong feelings about this i'll
stop the video at this point
thanks for watching and see you in a
future video
bye-bye